MAN: [inaudible] .
MAN: They're right here.
They just went
in this building.
Enemy just went
into this building.
[inaudible].
CAPTAIN QUINCY BAHLER:
Sayidi, I need them
to say that nobody is in there.
MAN: [inaudible].
CAPTAIN QUINCY BAHLER: Are
there friendly forces in here?
No friendly.
MAN: [inaudible] .
CAPTAIN QUINCY BAHLER: OK,
that's all I'm asking, man.
That's what I'm asking.
NARRATOR: This is
what war looks like.
When you're a captain
in the US Army.
When you're less than 1,000
yards from the front lines.
The last grid doesn't help me.
I'm asking them to confirm
or deny if that's them.
Sayidi, is this you?
Is this you?
Is it Daesh or friendly?
That's all I'm asking.
NARRATOR: When you're working
alongside Iraqi generals.
[inaudible].
CAPTAIN QUINCY BAHLER:
[inaudible] clear hot,
approved.
General Ali.
NARRATOR: When making
the final calls
that are the difference
between who lives--
Clear hot, clear hot.
NARRATOR: And who dies.
[applause]
CAPTAIN QUINCY BAHLER: They
have to seize the objective,
so they still have
about 3 kilometers
to get to the Tigris.
So this is one
victory for today,
but there's weeks
of fighting left.
NARRATOR: Officially,
Bahler and the Americans
are here only to
advise and assist.
But the strikes
they're ordering will
come from the American-led
coalition planes in the sky.
CAPTAIN QUINCY
BAHLER: Sayidi, two
Daesh on a vroom right there.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Are they reviewing the tape?
Yeah, they did review.
It's a possible weapon.
NARRATOR: Captain Bahler
does this all day,
trying to make sure what he
sees on his screens is right.
Captain Bahler for
Captain Fitz, please.
NARRATOR: That
ordering a strike will
kill an ISIS fighter and not
an Iraqi soldier or civilian.
[inaudible] strike request.
MAN: It's at strike, sir.
[inaudible] [bleep].
Hey Dan, just for your SA,
we've got 200 dynamic on a moto.
And we've got General Ali
here wanting us to strike it.
I think it could go a
long way if we can get
these guys to approve rapidly.
Yeah, they're traveling
straight towards friendlies.
We've got to start
working the strike.
Let's go.